also breaking tonight a cyclist is dead  another seriously hurt after they were  hit by a truck it happened at Flamingo  and Cambridge just after 5 30 p.m  Witnesses telling Metro Police that the  driver of the truck crashed into a car  then swerved into a bus lane hitting  both bicyclists investigators say the  truck then crashed into several other  vehicles two of the drivers that were  hit described to us what exactly  happened  we just started hearing feds coming in  from the background and then boom boom  boom all of a sudden it hit right in the  back it looked like literal Armageddon  around us there were nine ten cars  probably just sprawled out everywhere  some people stuck in the cars the driver  of that truck was also injured and is in  police custody at Sunrise Hospital he  will face multiple charges if he  survives his injuries